straight to a fox news alert
41 year old louisiana congressman-elect
luke letlow
has died from covid19 the shocking news
confirmed by his family overnight just
10 days after he tested positive todd
pyro joins us with the reaction pouring
in overnight todd good morning
good morning really tough news this
morning let low's death comes
as a shock to capitol hill the 41 year
old congressman-elect was
set to be confirmed this sunday let low
was admitted to the icu last week after
he began to experience complications
from kovid19 dr mark siegel joined us
earlier he explains why lelo's death is
so unusual vast majority of the time
it's elderly people that die of this or
obese and and the congressman was
neither
it looked like it was his heart rather
than his lungs
this is very unusual does not appear
from what i'm hearing that he had
underlying conditions
reaction from congress pouring in house
minority leader kevin mccarthy tweeting
our hearts break tonight as we process
the news of congressman elect luke
letlow's passing i spoke with his wife
julia
judy and i are praying for her and their
two young children during this terrible
time
house speaker nancy pelosi also offering
her condolences saying quote
as the house grieves congressman elect
let low's passing our sorrow is
compounded by the grief of
so many other families who have also
suffered lives cut short by this
terrible virus
let lo leaves behind a wife and two
young children
flags in louisiana will fly at half
staff for the congressman elect's
funeral
back to you thank you todd it really is
terrible news um
house minority wit steve scalise was
with us earlier today he was a friend
of the congressman-elect here's what he
had to say about this
terrible passing it was just
heartbreaking i mean luke was a young
guy
41 years old in great health and looking
forward to a bright future he had just
gotten elected to congress three weeks
ago was
we would talk a lot about the things he
wanted to do the committees he wanted to
get on he
uh boy talk about a loss of someone with
so much energy
he's got a beautiful young family i i
know my prayers are
with julia his two young young kids uh
you know the everything about this is
just
heartbreaking our whole devastate
delegation is devastated
uh luke is just uh you know one of those
people that everybody
everybody liked yeah that's uh
that's what makes this so tough you know
this idea that he's 41 years old look at
that family there
a wife and two young young kids he was a
former chief of staff to ralph abram
there he goes he runs for congress the
first time and he wins
he's going to get sworn in on sunday and
then to have this news
it really griffiths it's hard to swallow
it's hard to see